une journée pour se mettre en marche en
vue des municipales ce samedi 9 novembre
les adhérents et militants lrm des
yvelines se sont réunis autour d'un
campus à villepreux
l'objectif lancé officiellement la
campagne et définir une ligne directrice
c'est important pour déjà bien définir
l'application concrète de ce qu'on
trouve mieux comme valeur comme comme
idée de la politique locale et surtout
de pouvoir échanger ensemble sur les
problématiques communes qu'on rencontre
et partage les meilleures solutions pour
échanger plusieurs ateliers d'une heure
étaient organisées sur le site tout au
long de la journée au programme des
thématiques sur l'écologie l'éducation
encore l'urbanisme
c'est aussi la méthode de la république
en marchant c'est que dans notre dans
notre projet progressiste il ya cette
méthode qui est basé sur la construction
et sur le travail en proximité avec le
terrain
donc on arrive avec aucune idée
préconçue et l'idée de la journée c'est
que chacun puisse s'exprimer
au total plus de 200 militants et futurs
candidats se sont réunis autour de ces
ateliers parmi eux de nombreux jeunes je
suis venu pour me former pour sur divers
sujets on a tous une appétence donc
selon notre profession nos études nom
n'est pas compétent surtout donc je suis
venu pour apprendre
on a la chance de pouvoir profiter de
retour d'expérience des personnes qui
ont déjà fait campagne qui se lance en
ce moment en tant que candidat ou chefs
de file donc c'est venir ici pour
partager des expériences diverses
après une journée des changes le campus
est clôturée par une séance plénière le
département compte près de treize mille
adhérents de la république en marche et
une centaine de comités locaux